[Music]
The Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
releases on March third and according to
Nintendo it could be the last first
party game that comes to the wii u I'm
mad and this gamespot News Update is
ready to usher in the switch nintendo of
america president reggie fils-aime a
told polygon that breath of the wild
will mark the end of the company's new
development on the console from a
first-party standpoint there's no new
development coming after the launch of
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
we really are at the end of life for Wii
U visa may says there won't be any new
development from Nintendo so that could
mean we might see another game or two
that has already started production will
keep you updated if this happens to be
the case online services for the Wii U
and some of its high-profile games
including splatoon and Mario Kart 8 are
staying up for now these amazes they
don't have plans to shut the server's
down anytime soon for more news about
Nintendo and the world of video games
stay tuned to gamespot
you